no
[Música]
hasta hace muy poquito nadie sabía qué
es esto de la epidemiología de hecho no
sabíamos qué escribir esta palabra como
dice mi hija elisa las personas que nos
dedicamos a esta rama de las ciencias de
la salud no éramos ni interesantes ni
entrevistarles ni televisa bless y no
nos invitaban a la charla usted ahora
así
y aprovecho esta ocasión para que todas
vosotras y vosotros podáis seguir por
vuestras pantallas y hacer un viaje
epidemiológico qué es lo que os propongo
hoy en día y vamos a hacer un viaje
epidemiológico que nos va a llevar a
tres ciudades a madrid a nueva york y a
mexico a través de tres personas a las
cuales les doy las gracias desde ahora
que son davis maría y rubén y a través
de sus de sus vidas y de sus comentarios
vamos a entender algo tan complejo una
cuestión que yo creo que es fundamental
hoy en día que es no solo la pandemia
sino la salud y cómo nos organizamos en
las ciudades globales y esto me lleva a
empezar este viaje por leganés leganés
que es donde vive david que es amigo mío
que es peluquero y vive en leganés y
todos los días se traslada a la ciudad
de madrid como el doscientas mil
personas viven en ese municipio de
madrid
trabajan y desarrollan su día a día 13
kilómetros más allá de su casa
aprovecho para decir que la vida es un
enamorado de su barrio y nunca la deja
vencer
y ese viaje que empezamos en madrid nos
vamos a ir hasta nueva york hasta el
barrio del bronx donde vive a maría y
maría lleva 18 años viviendo en el bronx
y han nacido sus tres hijos y el bronx
es uno de los cinco bolos de los cinco
barrios de la ciudad de nueva york donde
viven dos millones de personas y ahí
estas personas han sufrido
históricamente una historia de
segregación y de discriminación como muy
pocas ciudades
hemos hemos conocido de hecho ahora
mismo en nueva york viven 200 mil
mexicanos que son la minoría mayoritaria
en la ciudad de nueva york así que junto
con nada junto con maría nos vamos a
desplazar a mexico a esta palapa donde
vive rubén y rubén vive en una de las 16
delegaciones de la ciudad de mexico que
es probablemente la delegación más
humilde de toda la ciudad de mexico
así que madrid nueva york méxico son la
que hoy en día ganamos ciudades globales
que son lugares que atraen trabajo lugar
de formación y lugares para
entretenernos y siguen atrayendo
ciudades y siguen atrayendo más
población y más población pero también
hoy en día sabemos que las ciudades
globales crean segregación segregación
social y segregación espacial porque
cada vez nuestras ciudades son más
desiguales y vivimos más lejos los unos
de los otros y nos conocemos menos los
unos y los otros y en términos de salud
las ciudades son como la salud de
nuestro planeta y la salud de nuestro
planeta sé que se caracteriza hoy en día
por lo que llamamos enfermedades
crónicas o no transmisibles que no son
otras que la diabetes las enfermedades
cardiovasculares los diferentes tipos de
cáncer y las enfermedades crónicas de
nuestros riñones y de nuestros pulmones
y esa desigualdad social y estas
enfermedades crónicas hacen que unos
tengamos más enfermedad y además la
tengamos antes y eso es lo que hoy en
día nosotros estudiamos en salud pública
le llamamos el gradiente social y ha
hecho que por ejemplo en la ciudad de
madrid tengamos una diferencia de 10
años de diferencia de esperanza de vida
entre aquellas personas que viven en un
barrio y los que viven en otro barrio y
repito 10 años de diferencia esperanza
de vida entre los que han nacido y viven
en un barrio y han nacido en otro y
viven en otro barrio imaginaos por un
segundo todas las cosas que se imaginan
que podéis hacer en 10 años y durante
todo ese tiempo que no es igual para las
dos para las dos personas
y en eso llegó en enero del 2020
llegó la pandemia de coronavirus lo que
llamamos hoy en día la pandemia de kobe
19 y llegó en enero y en marzo ya la
teníamos con declarada por la nueva
organización mundial de la salud como
una pandemia que ha afectado a todo el
planeta y que tiene consecuencias
sociales y económicas y sanitarias muy
desiguales para unos y para otros y que
todavía no hemos resuelto
y en esas los que nos dedicamos a la
salud pública y a entender la salud en
nuestras poblaciones entendimos
rápidamente que iba a ser diferencial
entre unos y otros pero muy poco hubo
muchas personas que nos dijeron
el virus afecta a todos por igual el
virus no conoce de clases sociales el
virus nos va a igualar a todos
y las personas que se han dedicado a
entender las ciudades y entender la
población dijeron como la famosísima
investigadora saskia sassen ella dijo no
es que el virus prefiera a los humildes
a los pobres es que los pobres están más
expuestos al virus y eso es lo que
nosotros hemos entendido en salud
pública que hace que haya tres veces más
contagios tres veces más fallecimientos
en unos barrios que en otros y eso es lo
que hoy en día llamamos la sinde ni como
una enfermedad crónica una enfermedad
infecciosa perdón se une a las
enfermedades crónicas que ya tenemos y
se une a la desigualdad de nuestras
poblaciones y crea estas diferencias y
desde esa perspectiva es como tenemos
que entender la pandemia y es como
tenemos que afrontarla y ofrecer
propuestas así que os voy a plantear que
este viaje que empieza y cómo no
continúa ahora mismo en la ciudad de en
la ciudad de nueva york a través de
maría vamos a entender como en los tipos
de trabajo como los tipos de vivienda y
como los mismos tipos de sistemas
y hacen que unos tengan más enfermedad
que otros y volvemos al bronx donde el
marido de mariah jorge trabajaba en un
restaurante en manhattan y allí es donde
se contagió y cuando se contagió maría
vivía con sus dos con sus tres hijos y
con jorge en una vivienda que compartían
jorge no podía tener trabajar de hecho
en el restaurante seguía abierto hasta
que ella se cerró y allí es donde él
contrajo la enfermedad que finalmente le
hizo le llevó a fallecer en el hospital
del bronx
y pensemos ahora en madrid volvemos a
leganés donde davis ha trabajado toda su
vida en la ciudad de madrid toda su vida
se ha trasladado igual que su padre al
centro de madrid para llegar a su
peluquería y nunca ha podido tener
trabajar ha tenido que ir seis días a la
semana a llegar a su a su puesto de
trabajo
y pensemos por un momento en el trabajo
de el 60% de los mexicanos que como
rubén en iztapalapa se levantan todas
las mañanas a las 4 de la mañana en el
caso de rubén y se va a comprar fruta a
la central de abastos de iztapalapa y
esa fruta la lleva a la puerta del
hospital de esta palapa para servirla en
formas de jugos y licuados que es su
forma de vida un trabajo que es informal
repito como el del 60% de los mexicanos
que no puede dejar de trabajar que es
una de las principales ingresos de toda
su familia
y rubén se sube en lo que se llama un
pesero un autobús o como le llaman allí
en méxico un autobús donde el auto 0 el
conductor les dice pase le pase le pase
de que hay sitio al fondo y en ese
autobús siempre está hasta arriba
y en ese autobús él llega a la central
de abastos de iztapalapa que es el
mercado de distribución de alimentos más
grande de todo el continente americano
es como una ciudad pequeñita solo
dedicada a la distribución de alimentos
y ese mercado que no ha parado durante
toda la pandemia se convirtió en uno de
los epicentros del contagio de la
pandemia en la ciudad de mexico y méxico
es hoy en día el tercer país más
afectado por la pandemia en todo el
continente americano
y ahora vamos a pensar en la vivienda
como la vivienda ha afectado la pandemia
y todos y todas hemos pasado mucho
tiempo en nuestras casas hoy en día con
respecto a la vivienda así que sabemos
muy bien la importancia de cómo es
nuestra vivienda de cómo da de cómo es
de grande de cuánto dinero pagamos por
ella de con quién da compartimos o no y
de cuántas veces nos hemos sentido
seguros o no
y para eso quiero volver otra vez al
bronx y pensar en maría maría vivía en
una casa compartida con sus donde
compartía una una habitación en la que
dormían juntos jorge maría y sus tres
hijos y en ese momento es cuando se
contagió jorge que acabó falleciendo
como decimos de kobe y en el momento en
el que ella pierde el ingreso de su de
su marido ella tiene que dejar esa
vivienda y esa casa de unos familiares y
ha tenido que buscar un piso nuevo ella
sola sin ingresos con sus tres hijos
hoy en día sabemos por investigaciones
en el reino unido que si vives con más
de seis personas en tu casa tienes más
del doble de riesgo de contagiarte a
todos nos pueden entrar en la cabeza muy
fácilmente que si vives con mucha gente
en una casa compartiendo los espacios
comunes
vas a no va a ser muy difícil que tengas
una cuarentena o que cumplas un
aislamiento y no hay que perder de vista
que así viven muchas personas en
nuestros en nuestras ciudades y en
nuestros países
y por último me gustaría comentar lo que
creo que es una de las terceras causas
fundamentales de la enfermedad de la
salud y también por supuesto de la
pandemia que son los sistemas de salud y
para esto vuelvo otra vez al bronx y
pensar en maría y en su y en su y en su
marido jorge trabajaba en un restaurante
como cuando se había contado jorge como
un trabajador tenía un seguro de salud
pero fijaos ese seguro de salud no le
cubrir el tratamiento por kobe de hecho
él solo entró en el hospital cuando ya
era demasiado tarde y falleció en el
hospital del bronx es que jorge la
diabético y su seguro de salud no paga
ni su tratamiento
ni el control de la diabetes la diabetes
es uno de los principales de las cuatro
principales enfermedades crónicas que
tenemos en todo el mundo y su seguro de
salud no le cubría a un trabajador en la
ciudad de nueva york
davis vive en leganés donde su padre se
contagió y perdió y perdió la vida en 33
días
leganés es una de las partes más
envejecidas de toda la ciudad de madrid
y españa es uno de los países más
envejecidos del mundo los sistemas de
salud a través de la atención primaria
tienen que estar preparados para atender
a esa población envejecida y están todo
blación con muchísimas enfermedades
crónicas durante la pandemia los
sistemas de salud como pueden ser los
centros de salud y los hospitales como
el severo ochoa se vieron absolutamente
saturados y muchos de ellos siguen
saturados hoy en día en la ciudad de
madrid'
iztapalapa por otro lado
a atención primaria o la red de atención
primaria es parcialmente inexistente y
la gran mayoría de la población sólo
accede al médico cuando ya es demasiado
tarde y llegan a urgencias por lo tanto
hemos visto tres causas fundamentales
relacionadas con la pandemia y con la
salud en nuestras ciudades desiguales
que son el trabajo la vivienda y los
sistemas de salud y por eso después de
este análisis me gustaría hacer tres
propuestas la ciencia nosotros los
investigadores tenemos que trabajar de
manera interdisciplinaria e
internacional para entender cómo se
manifiesta la desigualdad en nuestras
sociedades quiénes son los que más
necesitan qué tipo de recursos son los
necesarios y que esa ciencia esa
evidencia científica se traslada en
acciones y en políticas que puedan
llegar a nuestras ciudades para proteger
la salud de nuestras personas y de
nuestros ciudadanos y esto es lo que ya
se hace en muchas ciudades del mundo y
fijaos qué interesante es el uso de las
palabras la doctora mary based que fue
la directora del servicio de salud de
toda la ciudad de nueva york ella habla
cuando habla de poblaciones diferentes y
desiguales en asia de nueva york habla
de under search communities comunidades
poblaciones infradotadas o infra
servidas porque lo que está diciendo
ella es que no es que se hayan
equivocado o no es que hayan tomado una
mala decisión o sean ignorantes sino que
les hemos abandonado que no hemos dotado
sus barrios de las necesidades que
tienen la segunda de mis propuestas es
que la atención primaria hoy en día es
clave para poder atender no sólo la
pandemia sino las enfermedades crónicas
que son las que tenemos antes durante y
después de la pandemia y mi tercera
propuesta es que las políticas las
políticas fundamentales que son las
políticas de vivienda las políticas de
trabajo y las políticas sanitarias
siempre se hagan y se diseñen desde el
punto de vista de la desigualdad y desde
el punto de vista de la salud porque ya
lo hemos visto en la repercusión que
tiene el trabajo y la vivienda en la
salud
la pandemia es la gran crisis histórica
de nuestro tiempo y tiene consecuencias
muy desiguales tanto sanitarias como
económicas como sociales y es nuestro
deber ahora más que nunca aportar la
ciencia y las acciones necesarias para
proteger las vidas y la dignidad de las
personas como maría como davis y como
rubén para que nunca vuelvan a tener más
riesgo de enfermedad por el mero hecho
de haber nacido y vivido en sus barrios
[Aplausos]